voudrais rendre un petit hommage ce soir
puisque le chanteur idir qui nous a
quittés samedi à l'âge de 70 ans est un
monument de la chanson kabyle il a
chanté dans plusieurs langues il était
connu dans 70 pays alors il luttait
contre la maladie
bien sûr ça sa famille a précisé qu'il
n'était pas décédé du coc vide 19 mais
c'est vrai que ça a été un gros coup dur
pour tous ceux qui aiment
voilà la musique et pour les plus jeunes
qui ne connaissent pas bien on a juste
un portrait de lui regardez c'était un
très très grand monsieur je voulais
absolument le rendre un petit hommage
aujourd'hui pour tous ceux qui nous
regardent
voilà c'est ce qu'ils les plus jeunes
qui connaissait pas c'est un monument
qui nous a quitté ce week-end et je
pense port à sa famille il dire regardez
regardez chansons respirent la poésie
l'humanité elle représente aussi
l'affirmation d'une certaine identité
lui qui a toujours voulu défendre la
culture berbère d'ancenis imprégnées et
puis c'est une culture ancestrale une
culture de pas de guerre ni ni ni
violente mais une culture de
construction d'amour des changes
elle est là pour l'e mail est là pour
essayer de réunir les gens et on les
félicitera ici
un ayant atteint sur ses albums ou sur
scène idir aimait s'entourer d'autres
artistes francophones le partage et les
changes comme fil conducteur d'une
carrière longue de 47 ans pour celui que
l'on surnommé la zone à vous ou le
brassens kabyle
[Musique]
voilà et on pense aussi fort à soprano
un bien sur sopra vous savez que je les
aime énormément au sopra qui est un mec
exceptionnel qui a perdu son papa ce
week-end du coït 19 voilà je pense très
fort à lui et à toute sa famille et ont
même très très fort voilà on avait cuit
dans ce moment très difficile